20 20 Democrats stumble congressional
Democrats bumble can impeachment save
them I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is sponsored by
Express VPN your data is your business
protected and expressvpn comm slash pen
also you may have noticed that it's a
bit chaotic out there and when I mean
chaotic I mean seriously chaotic
everybody is watching the impeachment
efforts there's turmoil in the Middle
East there's conflict with China which
is about to take over Hong Kong again
well whenever there is uncertainty in
the world people tend to look for a safe
haven especially when they don't know
which way the economy is gonna go do you
know where the stock market is going to
be one year from now do you know where
your investments are gonna be well one
thing is certain you should be
diversified right every financial
planner will tell you that
diversification is key whether you're
talking about diversify within the stock
market or whether you're talking about
diversifying across a broad range of
possible investments and this is why at
least part of your money should be in
precious metals gold has never been
worth zero there's a reason that I am
diversified into gold at least a little
bit I've been telling you for years that
if you're not protecting your
investments in your family with gold
you're missing the boat
whether it's inflation and national debt
or whether its international turmoil the
fact is that gold protects you against
the vicissitudes of the free market
Birch gold will go to work and make
things simple they have a conversation
with you and you can determine if
precious metals make sense to include in
your portfolio again make sense for my
portfolio I'm not telling you to
liquidate all your assets and just buy
bars of gold I'm telling you you should
diversify at least a little bit into
precious metals it's a responsible thing
to do I know the folks at Birch school
they're good people
texts been to 47 47 47 today to see how
simple and straightforward this move can
be for you again that's been - 47 47 47
when he speaks in them be sure to ask
what promotions they are currently
offering talk to the folks at Birch gold
ask all your questions get your answers
and then talk about diversifying into
some gold texts Ben - 47 47 47 okay it
is day 2 of the public impeachment
hearings for the Democrats so day 1 was
a couple of days ago and that one
featured George Kent the bow-tied
specialist over at the Secretary of
State's office as well as William Taylor
the charged affair with the reassuring
gray hair again that description comes
from the New York Times reassuring gray
hair a phrase I have never heard before
while today
today an impeachment gate 2019 the
Democrats have brought forth another
witness Murray Ivanovitch she was the
ambassador to Ukraine there's one
problem she was fired before Trump
withdrew aid from Ukraine so why she is
there no one really understands except
that she is there to paint a picture of
an altar
mechanism by which Trump foreign policy
was being done so they're serious
complaints by Republicans by
conservatives that what this whole
impeachment thing really is about at
root is not so much
Trump quid pro quos and supposed bribery
what it really is about is a foreign
policy establishment that was very angry
the Trump had set up a back channel for
foreign policy that he wasn't actually
doing foreign policy through his foreign
policy team the professionals were being
ignored instead he was formulating his
Ukraine policy with the help of his
personal attorney Rudy Giuliani who is
running around Ukraine talking with
variety of figures and so by bringing
forth Jovanovic what Democrats are
really trying to do is put the target on
the back of Rudy Giuliani and suggest
that the foreign policy in Ukraine was
being driven by Giuliani not by
America's national interest because of
course Giuliani is Trump's personal
lawyer that is indeed the strategy but
if this is really just about Democrats
don't like how Trump conducts foreign
policy they don't like how he conducts
his presidency because he doesn't go
through the authorized mechanisms well
then obviously that's really silly
that's really silly okay so to go back
to the beginning for just a moment the
Democrats to recapitulate the charge
that they are leveling against Trump
they have settled on the word bribery
and their suggestion is that President
Trump was attempting to bribe Ukraine
and Ukraine was trying to bribe Trump in
order so that Ukraine could receive
foreign military aid that they so
desperately needed in their fight
against Russia and so that Trump would
receive dirt on Joe Biden my dad is the
bribe that is being suggested Nancy
Pelosi has been the most frequent
Democrat out there using the word
bribery you notice have they shifted
from quid pro quo which is a Latin term
which also quid pro quo isn't a criminal
act bribery is a criminal act so Nancy
Pelosi says that Trump has already
admitted bribery during that original
June 25th own call which of course isn't
untrue here is Nancy Pelosi making that
statement however Constitution quid pro
quo
bribery bribery and that is in the
Constitution attached to the impeachment
proceedings the bribe is to grant or
withhold military assistance in return
for a public statement of a fake
investigation into the elections but I
am saying that
what is the president has admitted to
and says it's perfect I said it's
perfectly wrong it's bribery okay so
first of all it is not in fact
technically bribery Laura Ingraham
points out correctly if a bit if a bit
didactically that the the crime of
attempted bribery is not in the
Constitution nothing actually changed
hands Ukrainians didn't do what Trump
supposedly wanted them to do and foreign
aid was forthcoming anyway and there's a
point the Republicans have made so if
there's a bribe there actually has to be
a bribe attempted bribery could
theoretically be a crime however that
has not been proved either so why are
Democrats shifting from this language of
quid pro quo to bribery it turns out
that for all of their talk about not
being nonpartisan and trying to hammer
down you know all of the criminality of
the Trump administration it turns out
that really this is about poll testing
according to the Washington Post several
Democrats have stopped using the term
quid pro quo
instead describing bribery as a more
direct summation of trumps alleged
conduct the shift came after the
Democratic Congressional Campaign
Committee conducted focus groups in key
House battlegrounds in recent weeks
testing messages related to impeachment
among the questions puts participants
was whether quid pro quo extortion or
bribery was a more compelling
description of Trump's conduct according
to two people familiar with the results
which circulated among Democrats this
week the focus groups found a bribery to
be most damning that people spoke on the
condition of anonymity because the
results have not been made public so
they keep saying bribery why because
their poll testing it which obviously
means that we should take their
protestations that this is not partisan
in any way with a huge grain of salt
their poll testing it in the
battleground states which thing will
hurt Trump the most and people say
bribery and oh well I guess that this
thing's bribery then I guess this is
bribery well Trump has responded to
these accusations he says like really
you think I'm bribing Ukraine in order
to go after Joe Biden you think I need
help to beat sleepy Joe here was here
was president Trump rallying in
Louisiana yesterday for the governorship
that that governor's race is very close
and so Trump was brought in to rally the
base here he was talking about Joe Biden
this just came out big story
new remarks from top ukrainian official
damages democrats impeachment narrative
Ukrainian foreign minister said on
Thursday that the United States
ambassador did not link financial
military assistance to a request for
Ukraine to open up an investigation into
former vice president and current
Democratic president can you believe
like we need help to beat sleepy Joe
Biden I don't think so okay and the
report that he is reading from is from a
source called Interfax Ukraine also
being reported by Reuters Ukraine's
foreign minister vadim priest Aiko said
on Thursday the US ambassador Gordon
Sunland did not explicitly link military
aid to Kiev with opening an
investigation into former Vice President
Joe Biden and his son Trump and his
allies are accused by Democrats of doing
it just that Trump of course has said
that the inquiry is a witch hunt priest
Aiko said about Sunland Gordon summoned
the US ambassador to the EU quote
ambassador Sunland did not tell us and
certainly did not tell me about a
connection between the assistance and
the investigations you should ask him
Prosecco those comments came a day after
William Taylor the acting ambassador to
Ukraine testified in the first televised
hearing of the impeachment inquiry and
Taylor had pointed to Trump's keen
interest in getting the European Ally to
investigate Biden and reiterated his
understanding that 391 million dollars
in US security aid was withheld from
Kiev and most had cooperated Taylor also
said that a member of his staff had
overheard a July 26th phone call between
Trump and Sunland in which the
Republican president asked about
investigations into the Biden's and
Sunland told him that the Ukrainians
were ready to proceed prosecco said I
have never seen a direct relationship
between investigations and security
assistance yes the investigations were
mentioned you know in the conversation
of the president but there was no clear
connection between these events so when
Trump brings that out he says okay even
the Ukrainians are not claiming that
there was an attempt to bribe or a quid
pro quo well that does carry some weight
obviously now what Democrats are gonna
claim is what do you think the
Ukrainians are gonna say of course
they're gonna say what they need to say
Trump is the president they want the aid
to keep coming and that is what the
Democrats are going to claim and it
turns out that now it is being reported
that a second State Department official
overheard president Trump's call with
the EU envoy discussing Ukraine and
investigations
The Washington Post reports that House
Speaker Nancy Pelosi said on Thursday
the testimony presented by two career
diplomats during Wednesday's open
impeachment hearing corroborated
evidence of bribery meanwhile it was
learned on Thursday that a second
official from the US Embassy in Kiev was
present when US ambassador to the EU
Gordon sunland spoke on a July 26th
phone call from Ukraine with Trump that
more directly ties the President to his
administration's efforts to persuade
Ukraine's new leadership so we will find
out if there was indeed a second phone
calls Trump denied that there was a
second phone call between him and
Sunland he says the only phone call he
remembers having with someone was saying
there was no quid pro quo all the way
through Bill Taylor says that he talked
to an aide who talked to someone who
overheard someone and someone was
talking with Trump about the
investigation we'll see what comes out
as I've said all along they're only a
few witnesses who actually matter in the
same query those witnesses are people
who have a direct window into the mind
of President Trump and his
intentionality with regard to Joe Biden
those people would be by name Rudy
Giuliani Mick Mulvaney the chief of
staff for the president of United States
v Gordon someone who's already slated to
testify next Wednesday so that will be
the bombshell testimony that's the
testimony that if you think any of this
matters actually matters and perhaps
John Bolton although we don't know what
conversations Bolton had directly with
from about the issues in Ukraine in the
meantime the Democrats are basically in
a holding pattern they're bringing forth
all of these sort of ancillary witnesses
to testify to things that we already
know so we already know the president
Trump was getting advice on Ukraine from
Rudy Giuliani and we already know that
he took Giuliani's words pretty
seriously he said so openly in that
transcript or quasi transcript of the
July 25th phone call with Solinsky so
nothing new is here so what Democrats
are really trying to do today is they're
bringing forth Murray ivanovitch who is
the American ambassador to Ukraine Trump
fired her and he had every ability to do
so but what they're trying to say is
that Trump's foreign policy is driven by
personal animus and by Rudy Giuliani's
information
okay well both of those things can be
true and that can still not be an
impeachable offense but the fact is that
he did fire Jovanovic pretty much before
anything happened right he fired her
before any of this discussion about
withholding military aid took place
Jovanovic was removed from her job
pretty early on in in
the last year right I lose it was not as
though she was there for any of this and
that's what that's what the Republicans
are pointing out today they're saying
like why is this lady even being called
also Trump has the right to fire an
ambassador for any reason she works at
the pleasure of the president even Adam
Schiff had to acknowledge in his early
morning hearing he had to acknowledge
that President Trump has the right to
fire any ambassador that he wants
alrighty so meanwhile Jovanovic is
testifying herself and she herself is
acknowledging that president Trump's
foreign policy with regard to Ukraine is
actually stronger than Trump's
predecessors policy toward Ukraine right
that policy toward Ukraine from Obama
was significantly weaker so you
voinovich is testifying and nobody
really knows why that's the bottom line
the only linkage here is to try and put
a target on the back of Rudy Giuliani
because the idea here is that Rudy
Giuliani and the idea here is that Rudy
Giuliani was manipulating foreign policy
maybe this is the predicate to Rudy was
doing work to go get Joe Biden then
feeding Trump that information who was
feeding that information to Gordon
someone but that is a very attenuated
chain of logic basically they're
bringing in Jovanovic to testify the
Giuliani was testifying badly about
Jovanovic and that Jovanovic is mad
about that to show that Rudy Giuliani is
feeding that information to president
Trump him because he fed bad information
to President Trump that bad information
was actually about Joe Biden and then
Trump took that bad information about
Joe Biden and CrowdStrike from Rudy
Giuliani and then afforded that's Gordon
someone who forwarded that to the
Ukrainians yeah all right if you can
follow all that sure ok I suppose that
she is tangentially related to this
investigation
so here's Adam Schiff clip 11 admitting
that President Trump has the right to
fire an ambassador so what the hell is
Maria vana that you've been doing here
for testimony some have argued that a
president has the ability to nominate or
remove any ambassador he wants that they
serve at the pleasure of the president
and that is true ok so then what exactly
why is why is she here why is she here
and here's your voinovich admitting full
scale the president Trump has actually
strengthened our policy toward Ukraine
so the idea is that we weakened our
policy toward Ukraine because he fired
Evanovich the evidence is simply not
there here's your Voinovich again
acknowledging the Trump's strengthened
America's policy against Russia by
helping Ukraine with military aid the US
provided significant security assistance
since the onset of the war against
Russia in 2014 and the Trump
administration strengthened our policy
by approving the provision to Ukraine of
anti-tank missile bottom line is that
the the idea that Jovanovic has anything
truly damning to say about Trump is
wrong she's never had a conversation
with Trump right she she's never had
anything really to say about Trump other
than Rudy Giuliani is feeding Trump bad
information which puts again Giuliani in
the crosshairs you can see the media
straining to try to explain why
Jovanovic is actually relevant to this
inquiry the best headline of the day
comes from the Washington Post about all
of this we'll get to that in just one
second first let's talk about how you
can make the best use of your firearm
well in order for you to be able to
carry your fighter on properly in order
for a god forbid in case of emergency
actually need to use your firearm you
want a holster that carries your gun
properly and also makes it easy for you
to access that gun when the time is now
well this is why you need a great
looking fantastically fitting holster
this would be We the People holsters We
the People holsters offers custom-made
holsters all produced right here in the
United States we the people holsters
even have their own 3d design team who
measure every micro millimeter of their
guns to ensure the perfect that I have a
couple we the people holsters they are
indeed fantastic they've adjustable
can't and ride they're unique and
intuitive clip design allows for you to
easily adjust both the cans and the
right of your holster so that it will
fit comfortably and securely at all
times you're able to place the holster
on your waistband and change the angle
also every holster has adjustable
retention and that is signaled with the
click sound so you know that the gun
ain't gonna fall out of the holster
custom printed designs happen in-house
the gap thin blue line thin red line the
Constitution camo and American flag they
got more designs coming out each and
every month we the people holsters start
at just 37 bucks apiece and they come
with a lifetime guarantee every single
holster comes the lifetime guarantee
every holster ships free as well if
you're a gun owner you need to not only
think about your firearm but you need to
think about the holster that you use
your firearm alongside that holds your
firearm and we the people holsters they
are the best right now listeners of the
ben shapiro show can go to We the People
holsters comm slash Schapiro enter promo
code Shapiro at checkout to get ten
bucks off your first holster that is as
low as 37 bucks and shipping is free
with an additional 10 bucks off using my
promo code again that's a We the People
holsters comm slash
promo code Shapiro at checkout for $10
off okay and then she would go on to
suggest that well Trump had strengthened
that policy he was also getting bad
information from Rudy Giuliani Jovanovic
s testimony is not supremely relevant
which is why you end up with this
idiotic headline from The Washington
Post for Trump ivanovitch's testimony
brings moment of reckoning on gender
what the hell moment I wasn't aware that
is an impeachable offense to fire a
woman I wasn't aware that that was
actually an impeachable offense now it
may not be a good policy but I'm like
what a moment of reckoning on gender it
feels like the moment of reckoning on
Jennifer President Trump came back in
the 2016 election when there is tape
that was revealed of him talking about
grabbing women by the genitals not
firing the Ambassador to Ukraine but
according to the Washington Post
during the pivotal phone call that
sparked a house impeachment inquiry
President Trump made a reference to
gender as he smeared former Ukraine
ambassador Murray Ivanovich the former
ambassador from the United States the
woman was bad news from told Ukrainian
President Vladimir zalenski on July 25th
he was just trying to refer to he didn't
remember her name okay then the other
trying to claim that he fired her
because she was a woman what are you no
impeach him for what sexual harassment
under Title mine or something like that
because he said the woman in a call is
olenski Trump them in nomina spur
diction as he pressured Solinsky for
investigations of his political rivals
she's gonna go through some things he
said of the ambassador well presumably
what he meant by that is that there was
gonna be information revealed about
Jovanovic but but the Washington Post
says his leading female diplomat the
political target of the president's
allies in a figure at the center of the
Ukraine drama Ivanovich has crucial
knowledge to impart when she testifies
at Friday's impeachment hearing she also
enters the spotlight has the latest
woman was refused to acquiesce to Trump
in the face of personal and gender
specific attacks oh my lord
so really the reason you bring out your
bond image and so you can claim that
she's a woman victimized by Trump's
patriarchal attitudes seriously that's
that's where you're going with this
here-here's ivanovitch the only again
the only thing that she's saying that
actually matters in any of this is
trying to put Giuliani in the crosshairs
saying that President was getting info
from Giuliani we already knew that
here's ivanovitch saying it it is in
America's national security interest to
help Ukraine train
form into a country where the rule of
law governs and corruption is held in
check unfortunately as the past couple
of months have underlined not all
Ukrainians embraced our anti-corruption
work what continues to amaze me is that
they found Americans willing to partner
with them and working together they
apparently succeeded in orchestrating
the removal of a US ambassador how could
our system fail like this how is it that
foreign corrupt interests could
manipulate our government which
country's interests are served when the
very corrupt behavior we have been
criticizing is allowed to prevail okay
so president Trump has responded to all
this by saying no I didn't fire you
because the Ukrainians were manipulating
you manipulating me I fired because you
were a bad ambassador and so he tweeted
this out this morning he had a couple of
tweets about Murray ivanovitch as she
was testifying which is always a solid
look in which she ripped into Murray
Ivanovich on a personal level right so
let me get up the exact tweets he
actually suggested quote everywhere
murray ivanovitch went everywhere of
murray ivanovich went he says turn bad
she started off in somalia how did that
go then fast-forward to ukraine where
the new ukrainian president spoken
favorably about her in my second phone
call with him it is US presidents
absolute right to appoint ambassadors
they call it serving at the pleasure of
the president the u.s. now has a very
strong and powerful foreign policy much
different than preceding administrations
it is called quite simply america first
with all of that however i've done far
more for ukraine than Oh
meaning barack obama yeah I do love that
he blames her for Somalia like Leahy II
may think that she's a bad ambassador
maybe she was a bad ambassador I don't
know I don't know that much about her
tenure as ambassador I'm not gonna blame
Marie Ivanovitch for things sucking in
Somalia I think they've been pretty bad
I'm not sure that was like people in
Somalia oh man marie ivanovitch before
she came here it was great and then the
ambassador showed up and now things are
just terrible okay but again the
argument really hears about Rudy
Giuliani and now there's a story that
Rudy Giuliani is facing a campaign
finance probe according to Bloomberg
Rudy Giuliani President Ron's personal
lawyer is being investigated by federal
prosecutors for possible campaign
finance violations and a failure to
register as a foreign agent as part of
an active investing
into his financial dealings according to
three US officials the probe of Giuliani
which one official said could also
include possible charges on violating
laws against bribing foreign officials
or conspiracy presents a serious threat
to Trump's presidency from a man that
former national security adviser John
Bolton is called a hand-grenade except
not so much because here's the reality
if it turns out that Rudy Giuliani were
to be prosecuted for bribery if it turns
out that Rudy Giuliani were to be
prosecuted for not registering as a
foreign agent then it appears that Trump
got duped not that Trump was actually
attempting to go after Joe Biden then it
just appears that Rudy Giuliani was
manipulating the president which means
that Rudy is the one who takes the cap
not the President of the United States a
second official said Giuliani's
activities raised counterintelligence
concerns as well although there probably
wouldn't be a criminal charge related to
that the officials who asked for
anonymity to discuss a sensitive matter
provided the first indication of the
potential charges under investigation I
would not be surprised if he gets
indicted said Mimi Roca a former federal
prosecutor with the US Attorney's Office
in the Southern District of New York
it's clear Giuliani is up to his ears in
shady stuff and there's tons of smoke
and so Trump continues to be tied to
Rudy Giuliani but again if Giuliani was
the source of all the bad information
then that's really not gonna hurt Trump
it's really mostly gonna hurt Giuliani
because Trump can claim probably rightly
that his personal lawyer was feeding him
bad information and he was operating on
the back of that bad information not to
get Joe Biden but just because Giuliani
was saying there's this corruption here
and involves hunter and involves Joe and
involves CrowdStrike and it involves a
2016 election this is why I say Giuliani
is is the Nexus of all of this which is
probably why Giuliani is openly joking
joking that he has insurance against
President Trump in case president Trump
dumps him it all comes down to Giuliani
now is any of this gonna matter in the
end probably not because we're do
Giuliani is is maybe he testifies maybe
he doesn't if he just says what he said
in his Wall Street Journal op-ed that we
read yesterday on the air then he's
probably fine either this all seems like
a bit of gamesmanship by the Democrats
more than anything else which is why
Ivanovich is a witness who doesn't
really matter all that much and the
reason that the Democrats again are
focusing in on this is because their
candidates are terrible we're gonna get
to the horror of the Democratic
candidates in just one moment but first
let's talk about why you need life
insurance well here's the deal if you're
an adult you should be worried about if
god forbid something should happen to
you
or let's say you become disabled you
need disability insurance where I need
home insurance or auto insurance well
there's one place that you can go to get
all of these things and that is policy
genius.com insurance is a very important
thing for you to have as an adult and
mitigates your risk obviously it's also
that time of the year when people are
looking into open enrollment for life
insurance so you look at your life
insurance at work and you think maybe
that's efficient the answer is it
probably is not most life insurance
policies through your work only cover
like one tenth of what your family would
actually need in case god forbid
something happened to you this is where
policy genius comes in policy genius is
the easy way to shop for a life
insurance plan that is not tied to your
job in minutes you can compare quotes
from top insurers and find your best
price once you apply the policy genius
team will handle all the paperwork and
the red tape the life insurance you buy
through policy genius stays with you
even if you leave your job and policy
genius doesn't just make it easy to get
life insurance they can also help you
find the right home and auto insurance
and disability insurance too so check
them out right now at policy genius.com
to get quotes and apply in minutes
that's policy genius calm the easy way
to compare and buy life insurance okay
so a couple of upcoming developments in
this impeachment inquiry so apparently
there's a career White House budget
official who's expected to testify in
the impeachment inquiry as we mark sandy
according to the Washington Post a
longtime career employee at the White
House Office of Management and Budget is
expected to break ranks and testify
Saturday in the House Democrats
impeachment inquiry sandy would be the
first OMB employees to testify in the
inquiry after OMB acting director
Russell watt and two other political
appointees at the agency defied
congressional subpoenas to appear again
that's not illegal they just filed a
lawsuit saying we can't testify until
the court tells us that we need to
testify the White House has called the
impeachment inquiry unconstitutional and
ordered administration officials not to
participate
Sandhya's career employee he was not
appointed by the president which again
suggests that presidents who come into
office should fire basically everyone
and replace them with their own people
he has worked at the agency off and on
for over a decade under presidents of
both parties climbing the ranks to his
current role as deputy Associate
Director for national security programs
he's expected to testify during a
closed-door deposition which is not open
to the public
typically the witness's first have
testified behind closed doors and then
they have testified in front of the
cameras it is unclear what exactly he's
going to testify to he may know
something about the process by which aid
was withheld but again if he was not in
the room for conversations with Mick
Mulvaney and president
and he's not gonna have any special
insight either so it feels like it does
feel like and the poll numbers tend to
show this that the impeachment increases
a bit stalled out right now and it
basically no one's mind is being changed
everyone who thought Trump should go
before thinks they should go now and if
that's the case then we have an election
in like a year so all you have to do is
just wait a year and you guys are gonna
get to have a referendum on whether you
think Trump is fit for office or not the
problem is Democrats don't want that
referendum why don't they want that
referendum because it turns out their
candidates are just sheer buckets of
garbage I mean just awful awful
candidates I'm talking about people like
Bernie Sanders even the New York Times
is now critical of Bernie Sanders 16
trillion dollar vision for arresting
global warming according to the New York
Times Sanders his vision would put the
government in charge of the power sector
which has worked great in the state of
California and promised that by 2030 the
country's electricity and transportation
system would run entirely on wind solar
hydro power or geothermal energy sure
sure I'm sure that I'm sure the entire
electrical grid of the United States is
gonna run on wind by 2030 in 11 years
yes okay sure
climate scientists and energy economists
say the plan is technically impractical
politically unfeasible and possibly
ineffective yet the criticism does not
appear to bother many of the young
voters who will have an important role
in selecting a Democratic presidential
candidate Chandler Condon a 25 year old
supporter who traveled from Denver to
Des Moines for climate rally with
Sanders says he really has some great
ideas that may not be past but it's
definitely stuff that needs to be
brought up people saying it's too
radical it's like well we need that
radical change but the problem is of
course that the policy isn't serious
and this is why Budaj edge is gaining
some ground in places like Iowa David
Victor a professor of international
relations at UC San Diego a climate
adviser to Booty judge said that the big
challenge for the Democratic Party is
that there's no serious policy he says
the progressive wing wants radical
change and climate change is one of
those areas where this has really been
the most palpable the Sanders plan
claims to deliver radical change but it
can't work in the real world yes
you mean that a life-long a communist
useless person is disconnected from real
world cause and effect who could have
thunk it meanwhile new studies have come
out on Elizabeth Warren's proposed
wealth tax which is a garbage piece of
policy if you don't know why I go back
and listen to Monday's podcast and radio
show according to Jim Tankersley there's
a brand new study out that shows that
Elizabeth Warren's proposed wealth tax
would
the US economy reducing growth by nearly
0.2 percentage points a year
every year over the course of a decade
to give you some insight into how large
a decline that is okay they're basically
saying that every single year the
average of 1.5% growth that they are
forecasting would drop to 1.3 percent
growth a 14% lower growth rate every
single year for 10 years every single
year the same people by the way tried to
assess how much president Trump's tax
cuts would help the economy and they
assess that the tax cuts would result in
point zero six percent growth every year
for the next ten years
so take the positive effects of the tax
cuts multiply them by three and make
them negative and that's how bad
Elizabeth Warren's wealth tax proposal
would be for the American economy
because the garbage proposal why is it
such a garbage proposal well because
it's gonna force people to liquidate
stock it's gonna be forced people to
liquidate businesses it's going to force
people to offshore their assets or just
leave the country entirely there's an
article in The Wall Street Journal today
by richard rubin pointing out the
Democratic presidential candidate
Elizabeth Warren has unveiled sweeping
tax proposals that would push federal
tax rates on some billionaires and
multimillionaires above a hundred above
one hundred percent for every dollar you
take in you would now pay more than one
hundred percent if you make above a
certain threshold potential tax rates
over one hundred percent could result
from the combination of tax increases
the Massachusetts senator proposes for
the very top tier of investors she wants
to return the top income tax rate to
thirty nine point six percent from 37
percent imposed a new fourteen point
eight percent tax for social security
and an annual tax of up to six percent
on accumulated wealth and require rich
investors to pay capital gains taxes at
the same rates as other income even if
they don't actually sell the assets so
in other words she wants to
mark-to-market so instead of you having
to sell your stocks if you if you have a
new very wealthy person you just take
your stock value and you haven't sold
them so you even realize the gain should
take your stock value the accrued the
accrual of the stock value and then she
would tax you every year I'm the accrual
of value that you have not realized by
selling the stock so says the Wall
Street Journal consider a billionaire
with a $1,000 investment who earns a 6%
return or 60 bucks received his capital
gains dividend or interest if all of
Warren's taxes are implemented he could
Oh 50 8.2
percent of that or $35 in federal tax
plus his entire investment what it would
incur a 6% wealth tax ie at least 60
bucks the result taxes as high as $95 on
income of $60 for a combined tax rate of
158 percent the rate would vary
according to investor circumstances any
state tax is the profitability of his
investments and as yet unspecified
policy details but tax rates of over 100
percent on investment income would be
typical especially for billionaires so
if you're gonna get taxed 100 percent
over 100 percent right you actually get
penalized for investing and making money
in the stock market what do you think
every billionaire in the country is
gonna do what do you think they're gonna
do they're gonna liquidate their stock
immediately before Elizabeth Warren can
impose this idiotic wealth tax what do
you think it's gonna do to your 401 K
he's gonna be good when Jeff Bezos
unloads 100 billion dollars worth of
Amazon stock into the open market just
to cash out because he figures even if I
can only sell it for 70 billion it's
better than being taxed at 158 percent
on every dollar I earn over a hundred
billion dollars I mean this is it's it's
insanity but she knows that it's
insanity and she doesn't care this is
she's a disingenuous terrible terrible
candidate everybody knows it it's why if
she were able to actually be nominated
she'd have some serious trouble in a
general election because this is
insanity it's insanity no matter how
much people hate rich people in this
country you know what they hate more
policy proposals that lower the amounts
of money in their pocket and that's
exactly what would happen your stocks
would go down your income would go down
the GDP of the country would go down if
Elizabeth Warren's policy proposals were
passed
she's a garbage candidate Sanders is a
garbage candidate and Joe Biden is
barely alive literally and politically
so no wonder they're focusing in on an
impeachment now in a second I'm going to
explain to you how Democratic policy is
wrecking one of the better companies in
the country
like that because it is they are so
interested in confiscating wealth and
destroying companies it's truly
astonishing but first let's talk about
how you can make the cost of your
business drop okay so I run a business a
lot of our business costs are tied up in
legal if you are running a small
business and you don't have the money to
tie up in legal then really what you
should be doing is looking at LegalZoom
like right now and by the way if you are
looking at Elizabeth Warren's well techs
and you've not yet set it set up a
living trust
because the estate tax will take all
your money when you die then you really
should be looking to set up a living
trust you should be looking to write a
will right all of these things can be
done over at LegalZoom over the past 18
years LegalZoom has helped more than 2
million business owners get started but
every entrepreneur knows that getting
started is just the beginning of your
journey and what happens along the way
will determine your success that's why
you ought to really paper what you need
the paper and you ought to do it at a
not exorbitant price legal zooms network
of independent attorneys and tax
professionals can help entrepreneurs get
started knowing where to turn for advice
on trademarks tax law changes and
reviewing contracts puts you at an
advantage plus you'll save money by
avoiding hourly fees since Legal Zoom
isn't a law firm don't get distracted by
legal herders hurdles and business
questions as the Year winds down go to
Legal Zoom calm today and find out all
the different ways they can help your
business and don't forget to enter the
promo code been in the box to check out
that is legalzoom.com promo code been
i've been using them myself like as a
business owner too long before they were
an advertiser check them out at Legal
Zoom where life meets legal
legalzoom.com promo code Ben so you get
some special discounts alrighty
in just a second we're gonna get to the
state of New Jersey attempting to wreck
uber right this is just the latest state
trying to wreck a new American company
that is providing a lot of people with
jobs and income I'll get to that in one
second first it is that glorious time of
the week when I give a shout out to a
daily wire subscriber today its Twitter
or Derrick Archer who understands the
importance of supporting your spouse as
they keep our country safe this is some
serious badassery right there in a
fantastic 3 tweet post Derrick's white
flair is holding her trusty tumbler in
front for f-22 Raptor and a video of her
refueling at mid flight which is utter
complete badass hurry the caption reads
after getting gas airborne from
refueling tanker while flying her f-22
Raptor the very greatest in stealth
fighter aircraft during a combat mission
somewhere over the Middle East
my wife flare also a subscriber needs to
refuel on the ground from the very
greatest and beverage vessels it's tough
being apart but I know she's out there
doing good work thanks for all you guys
do at daily wire keep fighting for a
country culturally and politically while
she defends freedom in our national
interest abroad we're not doing anything
okay that lady's doing something that's
unbelievable that is high level
badassery oh yeah come on
thanks for the tweets Thank You Flair
for your service unbelievably cool stuff
if you are not already a subscriber
you're really missing out head on over
daily we're comms
subscribe for as little as 10 bucks a
month you get our articles had free
access to all of our live broadcasts our
full show library select bonus content
our exclusive daily wear app which is
indeed a pretty great feature if you
haven't checked it out yet in fact last
night if you had checked it out you
could have been part of our all-access
plan which would have gotten you the
legendary leftist ears tumbler that
Elizabeth Warren is now imitating with
her billionaires chairs tumbler and our
brand-new ask me anything style
discussion feature that allows you to
engage our host writers and special
guests on a weekly basis in fact last
night after our daily wire backstage the
four of us actually sat in a room for
longer which was terrible and we
answered your questions on AMA in honor
of the hilarious self owned by Elizabeth
Warren tweeting that she is selling
billionaire tears mugs on Shopify that
will actually enrich billionaire founder
Toby Lukey we here at the Daily wire are
offering 20% on all access and insider
plus subscriptions when he used the
promo code Warren tears to get in the
deal on top of a deal again that is
promo code Warren tears one word Warren
tears for 20% off on your subscription
come join the fun stop depriving
yourself and join us we are the largest
fastest-growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
[Music]
all righty so speaking of bad leftist
economics uber is now being fined 649
million dollars in the state of New
Jersey alone for saying that drivers are
not employees according to the New York
Times New Jersey has now demanded that
uber pay $649 unpaid employment taxes
for its drivers arguing that the
ride-hailing company has misclassified
the workers as independent contractors
and not as employees which is absurd
because you can actually sign on as an
uber driver part-time you can decide
when you want to drive right you let my
employees don't get to do that okay
people who work for me and to me we
control their time that's why they're
our employees if we just had people are
like you get signed on when you want
sign off when you want and then just
kick us back a percentage of what it is
you make and you can use our app that's
not an employee that's an independent
contractor definitionally but the
state's Department of Labor and
Workforce Development issued the request
this week to Oberon a subsidiary razor
after an audit uncovered 530 million
dollars in back taxes that had not been
paid for unemployment and disability
insurance from 2014 to 2018 and because
of non-payment the state now wants
another 119 million dollars in interest
a spokeswoman in uber said the company
disputed the state's findings they said
we're challenging is preliminary
preliminary but incorrect determination
because drivers are independent
contractors in New Jersey and elsewhere
across the country states and cities
have moved aggressively to rein in gig
economy companies that depend on
inexpensive and independent labor
potentially reshaping their business
models we know what you mean is that you
are doing the dirty work of the taxicab
industry by destroying the ability of
people who might be otherwise out of
work to make a quick buck by driving a
car around that's all that's going on
here if you think this is helping people
who are out of work if you think this is
in some way helping the quote-unquote
employees of uber all what's gonna
happen is that if employers turned into
basically just a normal cab company and
that should have to hire these employees
they're gonna go out of business that
the entire business model does not
function under this under this rubric in
California a new law could require that
workers be designated as employees
allowing them to gain access to basic
protections like minimum wage and
unemployment insurance and I love that
they say that would allow the workers to
gain access to these things no it would
allow the workers to be unemployed
because would just stop operating
really and what's the profit margin
gonna be like at that point like they
have a slightly better cab app than
yellow cab or something
like that's not going to work their
carts you're making your your re
cartelize and you're making a cartel
again out of driving as opposed to a
free market what the left wants in terms
of economics now in other breaking news
turns out that the squad they don't seem
to understand the difference between
like campaign expenditures and personal
expenditures this is the third member of
the squad so far as I'm aware who's had
some sort of financial scandal related
to misusing campaign funds as personal
funds so we've had a OC and there were
significant there was significant
reporting that AOC was paying her
boyfriend basically from campaign
funding while while she was dating him
and I remember a few months back that
was the accusation anyway now then there
was no Hana Omar and there there's Nath
there's actually an ethics investigation
that apparently was open against Ohio
Omar for spending campaign funds paying
her married lover while she too was
married and then you know running around
on trips with him so there's an ethics
investigation into L Hanauma I don't
think there's one into AOC but there was
some allegations made about AOC and
campaign funding and her boyfriend and
now there are new allegations made about
Rasheeda to leave out the greatest
wisest and most honest among this
amazing I cannot believe it I cannot
believe this it is just devastating to
me I had counted on their honesty and
their transparency these were the fresh
faces of freshness and face I mean so
much fresh so much face faces of
freshness and yet and yet the swamp the
swamp or alternatively it turns out that
people who love big government or
justice have to be corrupt as people
don't like big government and in many
cases more so the House Ethics Committee
announced on Thursday it is
investigating Rasheeda Talib over
internal messages that she allegedly
sent in 2018 asking her congressional
campaign for money for personal expenses
which is a potential crime according to
Ryan's veteran over a daily wire the
announcement came in response to a
referral that the committee received
from the Office of Congressional Ethics
which alleged that two leaves campaign
committee proceeded to leap for Congress
reported campaign disbursements that may
not be legitimate and verifiable
campaign expenditures attributable to
bona fide campaign or political purposes
if representative Talib converted
campaign funds from Rasheeda to lead for
Congress to personal use or if
representative to leaves campaign
committee expended funds that were not
attributable to bona fide campaign or
pro or political purse but purposes then
representative to leave may have
violated House Rules standards of
conduct in federal
now this does go to show you by the way
I remember back in 2006 there was the
Mark Foley scandal on the Republican
side of the aisle so it's 13 years ago
now and there is all this talk about
Republican congressional corruption and
it led to a democratic wave in 2006 if
it were not for all the hubbub over
Trump there would be a wave of stories
right now about Democratic corruption
ranging from Rasheeda Talib - Oh Hannah
Omar to Katy Hill all of these new
democratic women might Hills already
start to resign her position Katy Hill
and she's already gone and now yeah bill
hanim are under investigation and
Rasheeda Talib under investigation and
allegations about AOC the Ringo Starr of
the squad remains the only person who
about whom allegations have not been
made I Anna Presley and it turns out
it's not relegated to young democratic
women either apparently there's another
house ethics investigation announced on
Thursday into Democratic Representative
Alcee Hastings over his relationship
with his longtime girlfriend who works
for him as a government employee
according to the South Florida Sun
Sentinel the Ethics Committee didn't
identify the staffer in question but the
case clearly refers to Patricia Williams
the deputy director in Hastings office
in his Broward Palm Beach County
District Williams who is the
congressman's highest paid staffer and
Hastings have been in a relationship for
decades and critics have raised
questions about it for years the House
Ethics Committee wrote that the
committee is specifically considering
whether representatives Hastings with
relation relationship with the
individual employed in his congressional
office is in violation of house rule 23
clause 18 a and whether representative
Hastings has received any improper gifts
including any forbearance from that
employee the committee continues to
gather additional information regarding
the allegations that that rule that
congressional rule is a member delegate
or Resident Commissioner may not engage
in a sexual relationship with any
employee of the house who works under
the supervision of the member delegate
or Resident Commissioner or who is an
employee of a committee on which the
member delegate or Resident Commissioner
serves so Alcee Hastings should have
married this lady is what it sounds like
because it says the paragraph does not
apply with respect to people who in fact
are married this isn't the first time
that Hastings has faced controversies
involving allegations surrounding
relationships roll-call reported in
December 2017 that the Treasury
Department paid two hundred and twenty
thousand dollars in a previously
undisclosed agreement to settle a
lawsuit alleging sexual harassment
involving Alcee Hastings
winsome Packer a former staff member
a congressional Commission promoting
International Human Rights settings
documents that the congressman touched
her it made unwanted sexual advances and
threatened her job at the time Hastings
with the chairman of the Commission on
Security and Cooperation in Europe where
Packer worked so there would be a bevy
if the media did its job there would be
this this wave of questions about
whether Democrats were handling things
ethically okay
in other news across the world the the
continuing battle in the Gaza Strip
continues it turns out that Israel
removing itself from the Gaza Strip
circa 2005 did not result in the
peaceful and wondrous election of a
moderate Palestinian leadership that
would make peace with Israel instead it
turns out the camasta covert a terrorist
group and now they are an open
competition with another terrorist group
Islamic Jihad for supremacy in the Gaza
Strip well a couple of weeks ago about a
week and a half ago Israel killed one of
the members leading members of Islamic
Jihad because they had information that
he was planning a series of terror
attacks on Israeli targets so they took
him out and this prompted Islamic Jihad
to fire some 150 rockets into the heart
of the State of Israel all the way
pretty close to beit shemesh which is
kind of central in israel there are a
couple of rockets that felt close to
beit shemesh there were a bunch of them
that fell in Osh cologne there bunch of
them that fell in Ashdod and put it this
way if Mexico started firing 150 rockets
into the middle of San Diego do you
think the United States would let that
regime stand you think that would happen
or do you think that the United States
would immediately topple the the Mexican
regime like immediately no
self-respecting state should be
tolerating this kind of garbage but
because Israel is under international
pressure and because there are no good
alternatives over there instead Israel
has been targeting specific Palestinian
Islamic Jihad targets right Hamas by the
way is celebrating all of that right
because Hamas is one of the reasons
Islamic Jihad is doing this is a show of
strength in order to overcome Hamas
Hamas is unpopular in the Gaza Strip
even though they have governed through
tyrannical hand there since 2005 as long
as jihad wants to take over for them so
you get to choose between two terrorist
groups if you're in the Gaza Strip which
is just wonderful just wonderful the
Osmo process of bringing terrorists in
to negotiate what the turns out that was
a giant fail and it has ended up with
more terrorists so you can't negotiate
with right now Hamas is actually risking
conflict with Iran by abandoning Islamic
Jihad because Hamas doesn't care if his
llama jihad gets wiped off the map in
fact they would prefer it
but Islamic Jihad is backed by Iran
Hamas is also backed by Iran
so Hamas is sort of between a rock and a
hard place either they side with
Palestinian Islamic Jihad and start
shooting rockets into Israel in which
case Israel goes in and and destroys the
Hamas leadership again and the
Palestinian Islamic Jihad ik leadership
again or they set this one out
let Islamic Jihad be devastated and then
Hamas consolidates its power now all of
this comes it is incredible all of this
comes amidst the European Union's
insistence that any product made by a
Jew in Judea and Samaria be labeled West
Bank okay so we are now gone back to
labeling Jewish products in Europe now
there a lot of people out there are well
under their just labeling it by area
yeah except for the fact that if a
Muslim produces a product in the West
Bank it is labeled Palestine okay there
is no State of Palestine it does not
exist so the assumption made by the EU
is that that entire area ought to be
owned and governed by the same people
the same terrorists firing rockets into
civilian areas of Israel not targeting
military installations literally just
firing rockets randomly into like
freeways and the Europeans have no moral
compass when it comes to this issue or
frankly many other issues it's pretty
astonishing okay let's get to a quick
thing I like and then a quick thing that
I hate and then we will do like a small
amount for Bible talk today so things
that I like so my friend Allie Stuckey
who is over at conservative conservative
review TV blaze TV Allie Stuckey was
testifying on the hill she was called to
testify about abortion laws and
Democrats had called a bunch of
so-called experts they called somebody
from Planned Parenthood and then the
Republicans called Allie to talk about
abortion and Allie started if you give
an excellent five minute presentation on
what exactly an abortion procedure is
and what is actually morally wrong with
killing a baby before it is born killing
a human life in the womb and Debbie
wasserman-schultz then goes after aliens
is well you're not a doctor so why are
you even here and Allie promptly just
Rex W Wasserman Schultz I just want to
clarify that Miz Stuckey is here
expressing her own opinion exclusively
and has no scientific or particular
expertise in this subject matter
whatsoever I think it says some
when I the one without the scientific or
medical background I'm the only one to
give you perspective specifics which
actually is exclaiming my time is ducky
my question was not as if not of you and
you have essentially acknowledged that
you're here expressing your own opinion
okay that is astonishing I love the
Wasserman shows has to cease back to
Mike because because Stucky Ally points
out the one thing that matters which is
she says you're not a doctor and she's
okay then why am I the only one who's
willing to talk explicitly about what an
abortion constitutes and Wasserman's
iguana you know I mean sorry I need my
time back my bad I need my time back
when she paused for Stuckey to answer
and she liked the question wasn't to you
yeah it was yeah it was Democrats never
want to talk about the truth about
abortion because that would involve
talking about the brutality particularly
of late term abortion which is not an
anti septic procedure late term abortion
in vara involves the forcible cutting a
part of human bodies right inside the
womb that's what it is
Democrats never want to talk about it
they always want to use euphemisms the
reason being once people get a good look
at what exactly this procedure entails
they realize just how barbaric it is and
the fact is that I mentioned on the show
that my wife is is pregnant with child
number three and she got an ultrasound
at ten weeks ten weeks okay so you still
had another I believe 11 weeks in the
state of California to decide whether
you wanted to dispose of this human
being at ten weeks we can see that this
is a baby just as like a matter of
instinctive sight right forget about the
moral arguments about the in about human
life and does it extend all the way back
to conception just as a sort of animal
instinct you can look at the pictures
because the ultrasounds are that good
now and you can see at eight nine ten
weeks that this thing looks like a baby
it does it looks like a baby even if you
were just gonna use the baseline stupid
Democratic argument that things have to
look like babies in order to constitute
a human life which of course is nonsense
right as soon as the egg and the and the
sperm meet now you have constituted a
new human life with with its own form of
DNA right but even leave that aside even
if you were to use these sort of weird
democratic formulation they you have to
instinctively feel that it's a baby
there's a reason Democrats never want to
talk about explicitly what happens
during an abortion or allow people to
see actual ultrasounds of their kids
before they abort it's why they have
opposed dramatically any regulation that
suggests that women need to be given
full information before they go forward
with an abortion by
while seeing one of these 3d ultrasounds
as I say the quality is so incredible it
really is incredible fact I'm gonna see
if I can get permission for my wife to
maybe show I have tape of the of the
first ultrasound of the new baby and
maybe I will show it on the air just so
that people can see the quality of these
new ultrasounds because it really is
pretty phenomenal it's really pretty
phenomenal okay time for a quick thing
that I hate is the Supreme Court
basically ruled this week that gun
manufacturers can be sued for bad people
using their products which is just an
absurdity according to Hank berry and
writing over at say Lee Weyer this week
the Supreme Court ruled it would refuse
an appeal from the Remington Arms
Company of a Connecticut Supreme Court
ruling that permitted relatives of Sandy
Hook elementary school shooting victims
to sue Remington the shooter in the
Sandy Hook shooting used arms made by
Remington the New York Times wrote the
case has been seen as a test of the
ability of plaintiffs to pierce the
legal immunity of firearm manufacturers
in the aftermath of shootings okay so
here is the actual full story so the way
that they make this sound is that they
make it sound as though there is special
immunity granted to gun companies that
do not apply to other companies now
legally speaking and that's sort of true
and it's mostly not so the reason it's
sort of true is because there is a law
specifically on the books that prevents
the suing of gun manufacturers for bad
people using their products but the only
reason that that law was formulated in
the first place is because there was bad
application of law in a lot of the
states so typically when it comes to
products liability right that if there's
a tort there's only a couple of ways
that you can sue the manufacturer of the
thing that hurt you right there there
are a couple of different types of
defects that you can sue under okay
design defect so a product was designed
and it was defective as it was designed
and therefore it did not fulfill its
purpose right the present the product
was was flawed from the very beginning
in the design like that you designed the
car and the engine blows up as soon as
there is some sort of car crash right
that'd be a design defect and there's a
manufacturing defect which is the car
was perfectly designed but in the
process of manufacture then there was a
flaw that cropped up and now the car
blows up when you hit somebody and
finally there's a marketing defect and
that is that something is marketed
improperly right they say that the
products can do something that it can't
do
the product says that it is in fact
inflammable when it is completely
flammable right that's something that's
a marketing defect now the problem is
then when it comes to a bad person
using a gun the gun manufacturer was not
involved in either a design defect a
manufacturing defect or marketing defect
right there's no design defect the gun
operates as it was supposed to
there's no manufacturing defect the gun
operates as it is supposed to and there
is no marketing defect because and no
point did Remington say if you want to
rob a bank buy our gun instead they said
if you wish to buy a gun here is how the
gun operates and then somebody bad
bought a gun or used a gun and then the
manufacturer was sued okay so there are
a lot of people launching lawsuits
against manufacturers cuz that's the
deep pocket it's very weird in Sandy
hooks case because in that case the gun
was apparently legally bought by the
parents and then the kid took the gun
from the parents after shooting mom and
then went to the school and started
shooting up the kids somehow this is the
fault of the manufacturer Remington
right so normally this makes no sense
right it makes like no sense legally
speaking to sue Remington but what
happens that if you're if you're a good
lawyer what you know is that all you
have to do with a case like this is get
it in front of a jury because you got
this in front of a jury and you sit
there and the jury rightly is gonna look
at the victim in this case the parents
of a kid who's been murdered and they're
gonna say okay those people have no
money and here's Remington the company
that made the gun and they have lots of
money
so let's gonna meet you ten million
bucks let's give me ten million bucks
right and that can bankrupt a company so
back in 2005 there were a lot of cases
like this in the early 1990s where gun
manufacturers were basically being sued
out of business by various private
parties at the behest of states the
liberal states okay so in 2005 there's a
bill that was passed that said okay we
can't have lawsuits that are being
launched on false auspices in order to
go get a gun manufacturer just because
you don't like on manufacturers and so
they passed that law so now there's this
lawsuit by the Sandy Hook family and the
Connecticut Supreme Court basically
overrules the federal law which is
incorrect and the Supreme Court says
okay we're gonna allow the lawsuit to
stand it's bad policy it's bad politics
it's bad law it's very stupid it's like
it doesn't make any sort of logical
sense it makes emotional sense it
doesn't make any logical sense and so
what you're starting to see is companies
like Remington that are carving off sort
of separate LLC's to limit their
liability analyses limited liability
corporation so what they're starting to
do is they will have if
if they're being sued under the auspices
of marketing defect then they will carve
off Remington marketing for example so
that way if Remington marketing gets
sued it doesn't bankrupt the rest of
Remington manufacturer for example and
all of this is is not good for the law
abiding gun owner who just wishes to
purchase gun none of it is actually good
for legal fairness in the country
because you shouldn't be able to just
sue a company because you don't like a
bad person use their product it's like
suing it's like suing a knife company
because OJ Simpson stabbed Nicole Brown
right like that that would be a very
bizarre bizarre application of tort law
and yet this is exactly what the left
wants to do the left has tried every
every avenue that can think of to
bankrupt gun companies they've suggested
for example that gun companies be
treated as though they are creating a
public nuisance as though they are
polluting the air which is idiotic
because again I have several guns
sitting in my house right now they are
not affecting my neighbors okay it is
not the same as a gun manufacturer
spewing toxic waste into a lake or
something so they've tried to say that
this should be treated as also a disease
that the Center for Disease Control
should study gun violence which is
absurd gun violence isn't disease and I
don't know and what rubric you would
suggest the gun violence is a disease it
is a crime would you study robbery as a
disease it's a very weird sort of thing
and would you study robbery like armed
robbery is a disease so only if they're
carrying a crowbar you then have to
investigate crowbars as part of the
problem all of this is designed by the
left you go after gun manufacturers and
destroy them and harm them and that's
why the Supreme Court ruling is so
indubitably dumb it's not only dumb it's
incredibly damaging so you know so much
for the conservative Supreme Court I
mean presumably there should have been
four votes in order to take up the writ
of certiorari all it takes on the
Supreme Court is four votes I'm
wondering who are the two who didn't go
for it my son shouldn't be kavanah on
Roberts right because there are five
votes that been appointed by Republicans
in recent years I would assume that
Alito and Thomas and Gorsuch all voted
to take up the case I would assume that
it would be Roberts and Cavanaugh who
didn't want to take up the case but
again that is speculation we don't
actually have information on that it's
it's a very it's a very dangerous ruling
and it does not bode well for the future
of gun rights in this country you
bankrupt every gun manufacturer in the
country it can be very difficult for
anybody to access the guns that they
ought to have under the Second Amendment
Remington's appeal was
titled Remington Arms versus ohto the
Connecticut case was Soto versus
Bushmaster the Times noted that the
Sandy Hook family's suit had used one of
six narrow exemptions to the 2005 law to
argue the Remington violated
Connecticut's unfair Trade Practices Act
the suit said the gun maker recklessly
marketed the eris ar-15 style rifle to
disturbed young men through product
placement in violent video games and
advertising pitches like consider your
man card reissued and the opposition
will bow down well again that that would
be presumably in a video game I don't
think anyone really believes that
Remington meant to sell weapons to
violent criminals who killed children in
a brief filed by 22 members of the House
of Representatives that supported
Remington's appeal they wrote in
enacting the protection of lawful
Commerce in Arms Act of 2005 Congress
expressly recognized that lawsuit
seeking to hold manufacturers and
sellers of firearms liable for the
criminal conduct of third parties were
not only without foundation and hundreds
of years of common law and jurisprudence
of the United States but also improperly
sought to use the judicial branch to
circumvent the legislative branch of
government to regulate interstate and
foreign commerce through judgments and
decrees that weaken and undermined
important principles of federalism state
sovereignty and comedy between sister
states and of course that is true
Connecticut Senator Richard Blumenthal
is a radical on the gun issue he issued
a statement saying Sandy Hook families
have successfully surmounted a
sweetheart federal statute favoring a
gun companies again it is not a
sweetheart federal statute it is merely
a recognition that the left is abusing
tort law and will continue to abuse tort
law and now in order to go after on the
one hand pockets that are deep and on
the other hand causes that they don't
like okay well that brings us to the end
of the show
quick note quick note hey this week's
partial because I'd missed it last week
the Jews every week we read a piece of
the Bible okay so I know we're a little
long but it's okay little little Bible
talk so last week was a was the partial
lexical I talked about on it on the
radio show but I didn't talk about on
the podcast that was about Abraham
leaving his home and I talked a little
bit about the importance of leaving your
home in order to pursue the adventure
that has guaranteed to you in the United
States of America this week the Jews
read the portion of the Bible called
vieira this portion is pretty rich
there's a lot happening in this portion
this is where this is where Sarah is
promised that she is going to have a
baby who ends up being Isaac this is
where
yes my Ishmael is kicked out of the
house after abusing Isaac by Sarah and
Abraham and Hagar is kicked out into the
desert also and then God forgives Hagar
and Ishmael which is an excellent
insight into the way that God pursues
forgiveness
the famous Midrash about that so Ishmael
right if you remember your Bible so your
Bible study is that Abraham and Sarah
have two kids right they have Ishmael
but Ishmael is actually Hagar it's good
cuz Hagar is Sarah's handmaid and then
there is and then there's Isaac who is
born of Sarah Ishmael is older so
Ishmael is apparently harassing Isaac in
some pretty serious ways Sarah sees this
she says to Abraham you need to get rid
of him he needs to leave the house
otherwise it's not safe for Isaac and
Abraham resists and God says you need to
listen to Sarah so Abraham says it's a
hey it's a Hagar and Ishmael get out you
need to leave this is not appropriate
so Hagar and Ishmael wander into the
desert and Hagar and Ishmael at this
point supposed to be about thirteen
Hagar and Ishmael are out of water and
they're suffering and Hagar basically
leaves Ishmael under a bush and she's
crying and then God comes to Hagar and
says you know pick up your eyes and
you'll see that there's an oasis over
here and and Ishmael is saved and
there's this famous Midrash which is
sort of a commentary on the Torah that
Adam breaks the narrative and the the
Midrash suggests that the angels say to
God why are you saving Ishmael his
descendants are going to kill an awful
lot of Jews what are you doing and God
says well at this point he hasn't done
anything at this point he doesn't
deserve to die and Hagar doesn't deserve
to die I can't judge people based on the
stuff that they are going to do I can
only judge people based on the stuff
that they have done right intent is not
anything and future events even if God
knows them he can't punish you for or he
won't punish you for events that you
have not actually taken place in as of
yet which is a good window into how we
should think of other people in our
society by the way makes you judge
people on what they have done you should
not judge people based on your
assumption of what they will do which
goes to the whole pro-abortion argument
that maybe we should abort more this is
sort of the Freakonomics argument that
abortion of impoverished children is
going to lower the crime rate that's
pretty ugly stuff okay the other aspect
is the most cryptic the ignore scripted
part of the entire Bible from the
cryptic part of the Bible is of course
the the sacrifice of Isaac and
commentators throughout history who hate
religion have suggested that this is
berrak and cruel obviously God telling
Abraham to sacrifice his own son is a is
a cruel thing to do incredibly cruel
okay the problem is that if you actually
look at the text that's not actually
what's going on if you look at the text
what you see is that God says that he is
going to God says to Abraham I want you
to take your son your only son and I
want you to take him up to a place that
I'm willing to show you and then I want
you to sacrifice him no he doesn't say I
want you to kill him this is I want you
to sacrifice him okay so Abraham doesn't
question Abraham says he Naini I'm here
and then he just goes ahead and he and
he takes Isaac with him because the
question is what exactly was going on in
Abraham's head why exactly wasn't he
fighting all of this right why why did
like you see Abraham throughout the
Bible is fighting back against God on
these sorts of things right when God
says he wants to destroy Sodom and
Gomorrah Abraham is the one saying well
how many innocent people are over there
what do you really want to do that and
God says okay well if you can find a
certain number of innocent people then I
won't do it but if you can't find that
number of innocent people then I'm gonna
go ahead and do it right so God
negotiates with Abraham he doesn't say
to every time you're not allowed to ask
these questions so why exactly doesn't
Abraham actually ask the question why
doesn't Abraham say well you're asking
me to do something that cuts against
everything that you have said that you
stand for right human sacrifice which is
a big no-no in the Bible a big no-no in
the Bible well what what exactly is
Abraham thinking well it becomes kind of
clear when when he talks to his servants
he says stay here with the donkey's the
boy and I will go over there we'll pray
and then we'll come back to you is he
lying to his servants when he says that
or is he expressing faith that God is
not actually going to ask him to kill
Isaac right was Abraham lying I don't
think so I think that in the in the time
that Abraham was was conveying Isaac to
Hara Moria which by the way in in Jewish
tradition is the Temple Mount and when
he was doing this Abraham came to a
realization God wasn't ordering him to
slay his son who's ordering him to
sacrifice his son he was ordering him to
offer his son right he was and what does
that mean to offer his son well what it
means is that every time you have a kid
every time you have a kid you have to
decide what values you want your kid to
have and there are certain values that
in today's society make your kid more
susceptible to danger it's been true
throughout history it's particularly
true for Jews but it's been true for
Christians has been true for anybody who
stands for a particular value system
what values do you inculcate in your
kids
living in a time when we are supposed to
inculcate no values in our kids
I know values the secular left mean
secular left values you're supposed to
let your five-year-old choose their
gender you're supposed to let your
five-year-old choose choose their
morality your Rousseau an emil version
of life is supposed to apply but that's
not how parents do things and one of the
things you take into account is should I
teach my kids things that make life more
difficult because they are the principal
things to do that put my kids in more
danger and this has been a very real
life-and-death struggle for a lot of
Jews over the course of time
particularly right because why would you
raise your kid Jewish if you know that
your kid is going to be targeted why
would you raise your kid Jewish if you
know that that's gonna make their life
harder well God is saying to Abraham is
you have to be willing to not only act
out my will in your life you have to be
willing to teach your children eternal
true values even if it means that it
puts them in harm's way now Abraham had
faith that God would not end up
requiring him to actually put his own
son to death and God doesn't require him
to put his son to death right he offers
a different sacrifice there on the top
of mountain but over the course of
history in a very real way Jews have and
people of every faith really of many
faiths and of many principles have had
to stack their own safety up against the
the reality of principle and they've had
to stack their children's safety up
against the reality of principle and
these are all decisions that we as
parents have to make and the choice is
unavoidable because the fact is that
your kid will be brought up with some
principles either they will be your
principles there will be somebody else's
principles and other people's principles
may not be right they may be wrong they
may be bad you have to make the decision
that yeah your kid might suffer a little
bit more for standing up for the right
thing but that's what being a moral
parent is all about instructing your kid
in the right thing and the moral thing
and the true thing even if it means
sacrificing some short-term joy in order
to achieve long-term fulfillment okay
well we will be back here next week on
Monday orange we have two additional
hours coming up later today so we'll see
you then I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Robert Sterling directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
assistant director Pavo why douse key
edited by Adam sy events audio is mixed
by Mike Carmina
hair and makeup is by Jess WA alvera
production assistant Nick Sheehan the
Ben Shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 19 on
the Matt Walsh show we're not just
discussing politics we're talking
culture faith family all of the things
that are really important to you so come
join the conversation